نتابع التطورات مع مراسلينا من كيف حسان
مسعود ومن دانيت كارمن جوخادار اهلا بكما
ابدا معك حسان والهجوم المكثف بالمسيرات
الروسيه على العاصمه كياف والاضرار التي
ربما
الحقه اسقاط هذه المسيره
نعم مريم هو الهجوم الرابع عشر على
التوالي منذ بدايه شهر مايو هجمات متتاليه
متصاعده بواتيرتها ومختلفه باشكالها تتعرض
لها العاصمه الاوكرانيه بشكل مكثف هذه
المره اتت هذه الهجمه
بعدد قياسي كما قالت القوات الجويه من
المسيرات الانتحاريه التي هاجمت المدن
الاوكرانيه تحديدا في المنطقه
الوسطى هنا في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
وفي محيطها شرقا وغربا هنا في هذه العاصمه
تمكنت الدفاعات الجويه كما تقول الروايه
الاوكرانيه الرسميه من اسقاط اربعين مسيره
انتحاريه هاجمت هذه المدينه والحقت اضرارا
في عدد من المواقع كنا صباحا في احد
المواقع والان نحن في موقع اخر سنشاهد حجم
الاضرار التي
خلفتها هذه المسيره الانتحاريه التي
استهدفت المنطقه والتي تقول الروايه
الرسميه اسقطت فاصابت هذه المنطقه وتحديدا
هذا المبنى واثر ذلك على المنشات وعلى
المبنى بشكل كبير وكذلك ادى الى مقتل شخص
في هذا المكان كان يقطن في هذا المبنى
وقتل بسبب سقوط هذه المسيره هنا حيث
تشاهدون هذه الاثار
وادى كذلك الى جرح عدد من الاشخاص بينما
كان ايضا قد ادى حطام المسيرات التي سقطت
في مناطق مختلفه في المدينه تحديدا على
الاقل وفق المعطيات الرسميه الاوليه اربع
احياء مختلفه
تم
اكتشاف فيها حطام للمسيرات واضرار سواء
كانت اضرار بالسيارات او اضرار
بالمنشات بالاضافه ايضا الى تضرر احدى
المن الكبيره التي تحتوي على مخازن كبيره
في المنطقه الجنوبيه من العاصمه
الاوكرانيه هذه الهجمه هي في اطار سلسله
من الهجمات التي تتصاعد وثيرتها نحو
العاصمه
بشكل ملحوظ وكانت ايضا قد بدات القوات
الاوكرانيه او الروسيه منذ بدايه هذا
الشهر
بالتعامل بشكل مختلف وبانواع مختلفه من
الضربات الصاروخيه سواء كانت الضربات
الصاروخيه فقط التي تاتي من مناطق مختلفه
ومن اتجاهات مختلفه وبانواع مختلفه او
كانت عبر المسيرات والصواريخ بشكل متزامن
او ان كانت ايضا عبر المسيرات بكثافه
كبيره وهو ما حدث اليوم عندما قالت القوات
الجويه ان هذا العدد الكبير الذي يفوق 54
مسيره اطلق باتجاه المناطق الاوكرانيه
تصدت الى
52 مسيره اتت من اكثر من اتجاه من الشمال
وكذلك من الجنوب بوقت متزامن